الازمات تلاحق شركه تويتر قضائيا وتلاحق
مالكها الجديد الى الماسك ماديا بخسائر
تاريخيه لم تعرفها البشريه من قبل لشخص
واحد البدايه بالشركه نفسها اي تويتر اذ
تواجه دعوه قضائيه لتخلفها عن سداد ايجار
مكتب لها في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو باكثر من
135,000 دولار الدعوى رفعتها شركه
كولومبيريت الملكه للمساحه المكتبيه
المؤجره لشركه تويتر في منتصف الشهر
الماضي رغم اهمال الشركه الملكه لتويتر
خمسه ايام لدفع المبلغ الا ان تويتر لم
تقوم بسداد مشكله اخرى تواجهها تويتر كذلك
او ازمه اخرى بالاضافه الى التخلف عن سداد
ايجار مكاتبها الرئيس بالاضافه الى
المكاتب الاقليميه وهي اموال مستحقه لم
تدفعها تويتر لتاجيرها رحلتي طياره
[موسيقى]
الملياردير لهم مسكن استحوذ على موقع
تويتر مقابل 44 مليار دولار في صفقه
جابتها دعوه واتهامات وجدل واستقال المئات
من موظفيه في نوفمبر بينهم مهندسون
مسؤولون عن اصلاح الاخطاء ومنع انقطاع
الخدمه طبعا كان هناك اقالات ايضا قسمت
صفقه بالكثير من الفوضى والمشكلات الشخصيه
لكن تلك ليست اكبر مشكله الرجل
اصبح لون ماسك اول شخص يخسر 200 مليار
دولار من صافي ثروته في التاريخ لكن كيف
حدثت هذه الانتكاسه له شهيد مصر
انخفاضا حدا في ثروته الى 137 مليار دولار
بعد تهاوي اسهم شركه لصناعه السيارات
الكهربائيه تسلا في الاسابيع الاخيره بما
في ذلك الانخفاض بنسبه 11 بالمئه الثلاثاء
وفقا لمؤشر بلومبرج لاصحاب المليارات وهذا
انخفاض من ذره ثروته البالغه 340 مليار
دولار في رابع من نوفمبر من 20 21 وظل
اغنى شخص في العالم لنحوي عامين حتى
تجاوزه في ديسمبر برنار الملياردو
الفرنسيه ورئيس مجلس اداره شركه الفي ام
اتش للسلع الفاخره
الويفيتون يعني كان نمو ثروت الى الماسك
مدفوعا بالاساس من حصته في تسلا بعدما
تجاوزت القيمه السوقيه للشركه تريليون
دولار للمره الاولى في اكتوبر لتنضمام الى
شركات التكنولوجيا العملاقه ابل
مايكروسوفت وامازون لكنها تتسلى على سوق
السيارات الكهربائيه باتت معرضه للخطر
مؤخرا ايديا الحق المنافسون بالركب رغم
محاولات الشركه طرحه اغراءات ضخمه
للمستهلكين الاهم صفقه شراء ماسك تويتر
للمساعده في تغطيه صفقه تويتر لدرجه ان
حصته في تسلا لم تعد اكبر اصوله وفقا
لمؤشر الثروه الخاصه
[موسيقى]